supongamos que tenemos el país y tenemos
al país de iu entre estos dos países
existe un intercambio muy estable
digamos que es uno por uno en el país
así entramos al mercado de divisa
extranjera podemos siempre obtener
moneda del país entonces tenemos
estabilidad en la oferta y la demanda
entre las dos monedas luego digamos que
por cualquier razón motivo o
circunstancia los cuates senna empiezan
a creer que el país ve es el lugar ideal
para invertir le quieren comprar el país
besos bienes raíces invertir en su bolsa
de valores sabe que si quiere comprar
debe debe mantener más moneda de la que
se maneja en el país ven entonces más y
más personas que nada quieren cambiar su
moneda por las monedas deben entonces
tenemos esta enorme oferta de as que
llegan al mercado de divisa extranjera
pero aún tenemos la misma cantidad de
veces que quieren invertir en us así que
tenemos esta situación
aunque las cosas se sigan dejando así
por sí solas donde hay una mayor demanda
para convertir moneda del país a moneda
del país ve y no sucede lo mismo para
con el país ven entonces entramos a una
situación en la que la moneda debe
aumentar a su precio porque hay más
demanda para ver qué demanda para
entonces la moneda mbe es más cara en
términos de la moneda de ha ash y si lo
vemos desde el lado de a desde su
perspectiva estamos pagando más as por b
y un argumento totalmente equivalente
desde la perspectiva de ver ellos pagan
menos veces por cada a ahora digamos que
por cualquier razón motivo circunstancia
tú eres el banco central del país ve y
no te agrada la idea de que tu moneda se
vuelva poderosa quizás no te gusta la
volatilidad en el mercado de cambio o no
te gustan los cambios bruscos en la tasa
de cambio porque suben y bajan
dramáticamente o tal vez que sus
exportaciones se vuelvan caras y que las
importaciones sean baratas que es hay
otros motivos tú eres el banco central
no te gustan esos movimientos en fin así
que lo que vas a hacer y con todo el
derecho del mundo digo tú eres el banco
central de tu país puedes imprimir más
monedas así que lo haces echas esa
máquina andar a todo imprimen billetes
imprimes por aquí imprimes por allá y
utilizas esos billetes que acabas de
imprimir para comprar más as y de esta
manera más o menos tú vas a reformalizar
la oferta y la demanda para los ves pero
que se producirá con todo esto bueno tú
sí mantuviste tu moneda en buen precio
respecto al país
y basado en el plan que hiciste esto
está bien pues era tu meta lo otro con
lo que terminaste fue que como imprimir
te ves y compras te hacen el mercado
abierto ahora tu hoja de balance tiene
un montón de as ya con todo esto cuando
las personas hablan de reservas de
divisas extranjeras lo voy a escribir
reservas de divisas extranjeras
es ley todo banco central tiene reservas
de divisas extranjeras estos cuates esto
es de lo que hablan el banco central
imprimió su propia moneda y fue al
mercado de cambio de moneda extranjera y
le dijo hey quiero comprar moneda de
otro país
ahora hay múltiples motivos por los que
puede pasar esto un caso puede ser este
ejemplo otro caso puede ser por
protección en un caso que la cosa se
revierta de una manera muy brusca el
banco va a querer protegerse